how do you get over fear in your life uh
you suppress it
yeah somehow uh you never
think thinking of what you need to do
to be alert to handle anything that's
clouding your mind see i grew up with
fdr
uh right the only thing the fear is fear
itself yeah yeah you got it
your father was a a pilot he wanted you
to be the first man to walk on the moon
isn't that the truth
my father really didn't understand the
rocket business all that well
right i mean he thought that uh you
ought to be able to rescue somebody
at the moon by sending another rocket
and people to
get there and bring them back right well
there was just no way to do anything
like that
did you feel disappointment no you
weren't a little
embarrassed you were in front of your
father no because it was no
no because he he was talking to people
that
uh when he didn't really understand the
background
let me he embarrassed you because when
he was lobbying and carrying on you were
like
he shouldn't have been in those offices
right now when president candidate he
said may 25th
1961 yes i believe that this nation
should commit itself before the decade
is out
of landing a man on the moon he was
right
and returning him safely a lot of people
don't understand
wait a minute he didn't say anything
about going outside the spacecraft and
walking around on the moon
he said to land a man on the moon and
bring it back okay that clearly people
in the space
business who understand the progression
of exploration know
that the very most important uh
contribution
of apollo was demonstrating the ability
to land on another object
now uh we didn't have space
walking until the russians uh had leonov
go outside the vashgod and almost not
get back in again
so we trained my very good friend from
west point ed white
to do the first spacewalk on gemini iv
with a maneuvering gun
and and we had to really convince him to
come back in again it was so
successful uh being outside the hatch of
the germany uh four
mission were you confident that nasa
knew what the hell they were doing when
absolutely absolutely yeah do you like
those guys they know what they're doing
when the president says we're going to
the moon we didn't know how to get there
we really didn't werner von braun wanted
a
uh a nova rocket which wouldn't have
been ready until
way past the president's deadline uh
1970 or so
right we had a saturn 5 under
construction
but his calculations brenda von braun
was that we needed two of them
to join up the stuff go to the moon
directly and come back
it was an engineer but weren't you
nervous that this was just
theory that they were rushing too fast
into this that they weren't
in other words because kennedy said we
got to get a man on the moon now that
they were just going to rush
and who knows this whole thing could
have blown up i mean you must have been
a little nervous about that
well they did test the rockets
and other people felt that
you could turn around and come back at
many times
during the mission right and you might
have to do that
like apollo 13 before you got a chance
to get to the moon
so we figured the chance just
unofficially the three of us on apollo 1
that it was about 60
that we would be able to successfully
land right but
95 that if we weren't able to land that
we would be able to come back
safely